in your tennis career because i mean you
were a professional
athlete at one point too practically
right yeah i was
um so i'd been very good as a junior
like
i was north of england champion got to
play at wimbledon with tim henman and
things like this and then i got really
ill
and this is one thing i want to talk
about um as part of like
it was not dealing with other things the
stress and stuff that had happened that
caused me to get ill i was out of school
for like 18 months
fell behind massively all this rubbish
and when i was 16 i was like no screw it
i'm going after my dreams
playing to win um so even though i was
good academically i moved to barcelona
um went to a tennis academy made it to
the professional circuit never got that
high because
it's just tough with finances and other
stuff but i was starting to play
tournaments made main draw a few times
um and then i destroyed this ankle so i
went off to university in america
so first in florida and then university
of south carolina number one
international business did that does
that completely terminate your
you know career as a professional
athlete no it did well
when i transferred schools um the coach
was retiring it's a bit of a long story
but basically
um i had a decision at a certain point
the ncaa says i was ineligible for my
last season so i had to like decide of
whether
okay do i just try and finish my degree
or do i try and go back on tour after
still being a bit injured and all this
other stuff
and one day i was just like okay no it's
time for the next chapter
um this is kind of done at this point uh
which was a really tough time so i know
some men like struggle with like vision
and purpose and other stuff i was on a
call today with one of the
community members and that was a time
where for like 15 years of my life all
my whole vision was tennis player tennis
player tennis player and
losing that was like such a tough like
depressing time
um and it ended up breaking up a long
distance relationship which again thank
goodness because it's not really a
relationship as you say but
it all just came tumbling down uh when
that happened
got it and how old were you when you
switched gears from um
you know professional tennis to going
back to school so
well sir i when i got injured um when i
was on the professional circuit i went
and got a scholarship and so i was still
playing tennis for a few years after
that
it was only my last year when i was
about 23 because i was a year delayed
going into
universities but i got through it quite
quickly so i'll have been about 23
when it was like my last year and okay
we've got to find a different path in
life
yeah it's interesting because um you
know your plan a was professional tennis
player
and i remember when i was about 19 i
think my plan at the time was to be a
a raf fighter pilot and harrier jump
jets because it was because it was
shortly after the uh
falkland war had ended and you know i
went to go and apply and it's like um
no you're too tall and you can't fit in
the cockpit so sorry we can't have you
but if you want to be a grunt and run
around with a gun and you know dodge
bullets you can do that so
that was a pass for me and i had to go
on a plan b but it was but it was a bit
of a blow to the head i mean like you
know when you have these life-changing
events
i think that one of the skills that guys
need to learn and need to
learn as soon as early as possible even
is how to pivot and adapt when
when the course changes for you you know
when the ebbs and flow kind of move
because that's what life is you know i
was actually thinking about it this
morning because i usually go for a
stroll
um through this wooded area in the
morning just to just to kind of clear my
mind and
you know some people will sit around and
meditate for me that that that two
kilometer stroll is
kind of like my meditation i was
thinking about how life just
continuously throws things at you it's
like you know the seasons will change
it's
it's icy one day so it's slippery as
hell and i'm almost wiping out the next
day it's like wet and the snow is kind
of melting so
i always find it's interesting to hear
other guys story when life throws their
curveball and they're like all right
plan a's dead let's beat it with a stick
behind the bar and bury it six feet
under call it a day we've got to figure
out the next thing so
how did you move on to the next thing
like what was the strategy after that
was it like the corporate job what did
you want to do from there oh
yeah it was cry and be so i feel sorry
for myself and play a lot of online
chess to try and keep that competitive
spirit
um up i cut i noticed in some of your
videos the chess board behind you i'm
like yeah i can't i can't go near online
chess i'm so addicted
to it because it brings back all those
memories of like ah
i need to beat something and do
something here
but base your competitor right yeah
definitely a competitor um it's
it's just such a drive for so many guys
um even in a mastermind i joined
recently i
um i messaged the main guy and i said we
should create a little side pool where
everyone competes for like their entry
of who gets the best results and stuff
like that
so i didn't thrive on competition but
the way i dug myself out is i was
already doing lots of stuff
anyway um like i saw a student run hedge
fund and other things
and got to meet warren buffett because
of that which was pretty cool
um and asked him a couple of questions
but the
i knew i was going to try and get like a
job
in either investment banking or wealth
management or something
even though i always knew i wanted to be
an entrepreneur i'd come from single mom
household but she'd been an entrepreneur
and
built a businesses same with my dad when
he was around for the first few years
he was an electrical con tracked on like
massive ships
and so i'd always seen that like freedom
side of things
or what should be freedom uh if you set
it up properly
and so i thought maybe if i know the
guys with the money later i'll be able
to get into that but
all my network was in america and so
even though merrill lynch and these
other companies wanting to hire me
there's just no
visa that they could give me so i came
back to the uk with my tails kind of
between my legs and had to start again
in november which is a terrible time to
look for a job
got it
you